oh
[ __ ] are not made for walking
actually it's contessa valentina allegri
whoa deep cut oh it's hard but i don't
like to repeat myself so you can just
call me val
but don't call me val just keep it in
your head well
we're gonna have some explaining to do i
guess making a shield
oh my god oh my god this man this man is
crazy
this man crazy he's trying to be captain
america so bad
john walker made that said okay
this man is crazy welcome back to new
rock stars the falcon of the winter
soldier episode 5
reveals these boots were made for julie
louis dreyfus
as contessa valentina allegra de
fontaine
a.k.a val aka madame hydra
big cameo promised for this episode a
big actor
a marvel character not so big but hey
one you're now here on youtube looking
for an explanation for who the hell this
is whereas we like to say what the
falcon this is inside marvel new rock
stars after show for the falcon and the
winter soldier
i'm eric voss here with mt how you
feeling empty
i'm feeling good i am so glad that we
got elaine in the mcu now seinfeld
confirmed
seinfeld uh vice president slash
president selena meyer
or old christine i mean
we're so veep she won an emmy for it she
wanted to curse this baby that's what
she said
as if her career has ever been cursed
she said one of the best careers
of any tv seriously she's so amazingly
talented
she is amazing god she was on snl when
she was like a teenager
and she crushes it in those sketches in
the 80s yeah
uh while she's now in the mcu playing a
character that
who knows there's basically five
different directions they could be going
with this character
and t and i are gonna lay those out for
you but um
let's talk about what happened this
episode mt so episode five opens with
this
amazing battle oh my god it was so good
i love the stunts on this oh they beat
john walker's ass
and they they break his arm to get that
shield
off hard civil war vibes by
it dude civil war light it was beautiful
civil war music
in there that jackman worked in oh it
was such a beautiful shot sequence
they used his body as a baseball bat
to end it i loved it did that team up
like with the at the very end with the
with the
using his jet pack to like hit him oh my
god yeah right the the ram i clapped i
physically clapped i couldn't handle it
now uh
walker surprisingly gets uh smackdown
from his government overseer stripped of
his title
and then he gets approached by julie
louis-dreyfus as contestant valentina
de pontayne we'll get uh we'll talk
about her
more in a bit but uh basically sam
ends up leaving his broken wings with
taurus says keep him
and almost a kind of iron man oh next
time baby
you know uh setting up tourists maybe to
be a future falcon
then bucky hands over zemo to the dora
melange
great moment and uh and then he calls on
them for a favor
they're saying they're going to bring
zemo to the raft which is interesting
that they're overseeing that prison from
civil war
um but yeah they end up building this
new tech for sam that we don't get to
see this episode but he opens a
briefcase and kind of a pulp fiction
uh uh 666 briefcase uh moment where he
just sees the glow on his face so we
don't know what it is
and then sam also revisits with isaiah
bradley in this amazing
such a good talk it was some real [ __ ]
man it was like two
black guys talking and like you know
like i feel like we don't get a lot of
scenes in the mcu where it's just two
people of color talking and like it was
so nice to see that
and it like acknowledging their race
like there was no
shying away like they're fully talking
the way people would be talking right
now
and dealing with like uh no
self-respecting black man would want
that
shield and such a powerful statement
yeah and again more heartbreak
that means so dirty it's so sad yeah but
hey good news is they fixed the family
boat
they did yeah the whole neighborhood got
together old block party
fixed the family boat and sarah couldn't
go through with it
anyway yeah no no way um and then
bucky and steve finally get to have like
a nice chat and we finally get to see
why these two
really need each other is you have like
the soldier who still hasn't gotten over
his past trauma
and uh the grief counselor can kind of
help him through that
um like the proper therapist sam did a
great job
um doing some uh accidental counseling
on bucky while they were tossing the
shield
up i was like oh i thought bucky would
get mad at that but he was pretty cool
with it
yeah exactly and we get this little line
where bucky says well when steve and i
planned it out ahead of time to give you
the shield
just kind of giving us some more context
to end game but i love this because it
also implies that
uh bucky and steve must have talked when
before steve went back in time to return
all the stones
and so steve like remembered that deal
that he made with bucky
and his view of like 70 80 years of
living out an alternate life
and then coming back and he's like oh
remember that plan we had
[ __ ] and give the shield to sam i'm
still going through with that
so you nod as if you're okay with this
trip right i'm surprised he even
remembered i mean like at that age i
feel like your memory just slips away
so that's a sharp super soldier memory
he gives the shield to like a duck in
that pod
hey hello sam i haven't seen you in such
a long time i remember how you used to
quack
so beautiful quacked in america that's
your name now
in the spider-ham universe quacked in
america let's get it
that's america's tale feather um but
hey we got some flag smashers intrigue
they get these new recruits using that
amazing app
whatever it is and then they plot to
attack the grc vote on the patch act and
they get the help of batroc who was sent
by sharon carter
so sharon carter and bad truck have a
side thing going on
we'll talk about that uh and then we get
this post credits in which john walker
hammers together
his own homemade shield in his garage
just
pretending to be captain america no
matter what he is captain america
and no one's gonna stop him apparently
but yeah
so let's talk about who val is let's
talk about john walker's next move
what's going on with sharon carter and
bad truck and
this mystery tech that the wakandans
hooked up sam with
but uh real quick i am wearing our
latest obsession shirt anarchy assembled
which you can get at
newrockstarsmerch.com but also also also
we just released
a new zemo inspired design who's really
pulling the strings
it's it's a cool cool looking shirt
looks amazing
so be sure to get your hands on that one
now if you do get the anarchy assembled
shirt you will unlock an additional
option to write in a custom shout out
that will appear at the bottom of these
inside marvel
after shows for example we got our man
ramon norville who asked would steve
rogers have
zemo right back to lock up or agree with
bucky
that he is a means to an end um
i this interesting question i think um
steve rogers would agree with the dorm
elijah and keep him locked up
yeah i think that steve rogers would
have never even
released zemo from prison at all he
would just be like there has to be a way
like we can do this without releasing
such a
terrible person out into the world so
yeah he he wouldn't be on board with
zemo at all i think
steve rogers would have seen the logic
of this narrative that maybe it's not
that necessary to have zemo involved
with it but it might just be really fun
to see him dance in one episode
let's get zima out of prison just for
dancing um right and for that alone
i've loved having zemo on on board with
us um
oh marisa says mephisto train zola train
i'm here for it xoxo rizabu
oh that's a great nickname uh but yes we
agree and uh
depending on how you look at valve zola
might be more likely to appear
now yes that's the first thing i thought
when i saw val i was like
wait hydra i mean like well first thing
i thought when i did some research on
val afterwards
yes i was like oh my god hydra uh zola
that's probably coming right and then
kyle brown said please tell tommy that
my mother and i truly miss him
uh go bills from tommy jr oh my god
oh tommy call your sons you have
thousands of them across the western new
york area
call them um all right mt what's our
first
uh what the falcon well obviously our
first what the falcon of the day is
going to be who the falcon
is val okay let's talk about it
julie louie dreyfus is playing val
contessa valentina allegra de fontaine
a long time shield agent in the marvel
comics that's right she also briefly
goes
under the name madame hydra and at one
point becomes a love interest to nick
fury actually in the uh the old 90s uh
david hasselhoff nick fury movie she
does appear in that movie
uh not mcu canon unfortunately should be
it shouldn't be timeline maybe
multiverse of madness will make it
mcu canon who knows
now if you didn't know this name do not
feel bad it's okay if you didn't
know this name i'm not we're gonna open
up the gate
uh all gatekeepers do not get behind
this character and say if you don't know
this is you're not true marvel fan
because she
is one of the lesser famous marvel names
uh but she does appear over and over
again she uh she first appeared in
strange tales 159 in 1967.
she shows up a lot in association with
nick fury sometimes with dum-dum dugan
from helen commandos
um she's this shield agent she's a
badass she's a fierce combatant
um she has an important role in the
secret invasion comics
she gets replaced by a scroll in order
to try to get more information from nick
fury
but she also has an important role in
the dark rain storyline that's when
norman osborn is controlling national
security
at one point as agent 14 that's her
designation she joins
sharon carter agent 13 in what's called
the femme
force it's a female assault team to
fight for female equality under shield
and now there is another time that she
joins hydra
and she takes on the name madame hydra
um which is what a lot of people are
seeing right now people are like oh
she's madame hydra hydra it's all hydra
but i don't know about this just because
that
storyline where she joins hydra is
really just a ploy to corrupt her
she never fully commits to hydra yeah
she's kind of
really aligned with leviathan i believe
um in that story
right right so that's going to be weird
like
it i mean kevin feige could easily just
be like all right she's madame hydra
she's the new head of hydra and like
heidi is coming back
but um you know in the comics she's not
really mad at my dress she's sort of
like pretending in a way
exactly but as we know like they're they
take these characters in directions that
they want to go it doesn't matter if it
was only a small thing in the comics
they're not really in the comics and the
mcu is a whole different universe so
yeah she could totally just be madame
hydra
newfound hydra and it's as simple as
that um now
let's break down what we know about her
from this scene she's this um
mischievous recruiter she's got this
maybe indigo colored streak in her hair
um she's got this card with nothing
written on it though maybe put a black
light on there or hold it up to the
light maybe there's some kind of secret
code
i think only crazy people can read the
card
john walker once he reads a certain
level of crazy like oh it's her it's her
phone number cool
she sympathizes with john walker for
killing nico that might just be
something she says to him but
i don't think a truly noble character
would come to him like that
yeah um but she says interestingly that
he did the right thing
by taking the serum and that it has made
him quote very very valuable to certain
people
and she knows things that surprise john
walker like she knows he doesn't have
the shield
she knows he took he took the serum
which is something i don't think the
government knows
uh and she says the shield doesn't
belong to the government
as if she has some kind of governmental
understanding she calls it a legal gray
area yeah
i feel like all signs point to hydra man
like for me
it's just like she just knows too much
about the inner workings of government
and like she's just she knows too much
about what he's doing
and just like it's just i think hydra is
slowly building themselves up again like
they always do
cut off one head yeah hydra is
definitely uh one
definite avenue they could be going down
um
because you know hydra has come up a few
times in this show
they've talked about how hydra was
involved in replicating the super
soldier serum
hydra is always evil uh and they're
they're it's one classically you cut off
one head more four minutes place you can
never
fully uproot hydra from the world
unless you jump on the hydra's back
sorry that was kind of march 2 reference
that's how you get it
um but if uh if she is madame hydro that
does
surprisingly give some more fuel to our
zola handbag
no if zola shows up in episode six i'm
going to scream you're going to hear
a sonic boom and that's going to be me
screaming
um continue sorry no yes so that is
absolutely one direction they could be
going another direction that maybe is
the same direction as this is she could
be the power broker a lot of people were
saying does this mean she's a power
broker now
um i'm not so sure about that
not just because they keep referencing
the how the power broker as he
or him uh and they would have to say aha
that was actually a misdirect and the
general viewers were like well i didn't
pick up on that anyway it's like well
for the
you know for the um 15 of you super fans
who did pick up on the pronouns
it was actually a misdirect that we said
just to
just to fool you seems a little silly
um but it's possible i you know whatever
i just think that
they would have to explain that she has
some kind of connection to sharon carter
uh maybe they would base that on the
femme force and the he
pronouns might have been ironic there i
feel like a lot of fans would roll their
eyes at that
but uh just because it feels like uh not
like something that
would shock me that much but just feels
like extra steps
yeah um and the same way that like a lot
of other people are saying well sharon
carter must be the power broker
possible it's just like why would the
power broker have these
mystique not x-men mystique but
lowercase and mystique
signs all over magic we're saying the
power broker is watching yeah and then
butterflies are like oh yeah she goes to
this bar all the time
she's sitting right next to me yeah of
course she's watching it it just feels
like why would
sharon carter be doing all these things
if she's also the power broker someone
who's
supposed to be in the shadows behind the
scenes but not afraid to get her hands
dirty not only making art deals but
killing people in shipyards
uh and if uh julie dreyfus is a power
broker it just play this out next
episode it'd have to be a scene where
like
you know one of the armed guards to
sharon carter says um
ms carter the power broker is here and
she goes okay
clear the room give me the room and then
the door opens and it's
julia louis dreyfus again like we just
already had this character revealed in
episode five
and then you look back at episode five
and say well then why did they reveal
the power broker that way
talking to john carter um well a way
that they could potentially do it and
this is me
putting on my conspiracy hat and it's
not really out of left field but like
yeah like what you brought up earlier uh
this character
was impersonated by a squirrel in this
secret invasion
so maybe a squirrel is being both julia
louis dreyfus and
whatever this male character is playing
dual roles
as they shape-shift between two people
so maybe
like um this uh val character is
uh how the power broker walks the scroll
power broker walks around
um and as a like as a liaison sort of
like um
liam neeson's character was in the
batman begins like he was really
cool but he was pretending to be ducard
so
yeah it would be i i that would be a
avenue but like
i think that's too complicated i feel
like this is a very grounded
non-cosmic series but i'm just throwing
that idea out there sure i think the
scrolls is a totally
third option absolutely it just we have
to wait and see
what new property they're setting up but
if it is secret invasion she
you know um the contessa does have an
important role in the secret of asian
comics and maybe that's what they're
setting up
um i'm just kind of wondering what her
deal is with sharon
like now sharon we find out is setting
up bad truck
to not setting up but asking for his
help paying him
to help the flag smashers disrupt the
grc from passing the patch act
um so maybe the power broker whoever
they are has some interest in
disrupting the grc but um the power
broker also hates carly morgan though
and wants to kill her so why would they
arrange a deal to work with her i
have some other thoughts about what
sharon carter's real mo is i i honestly
feel like sharon carter is is probably
undercover working for some type of
um governmental organization because
okay and
including bat truck i feel like batroc
is like i don't know if it's like a
thunderbolty type of thing or like i
don't know but like
it's just it just seems that this is
very out of character for sharon carter
to send batroc to kill sam or to to
interrupt anything that grc is doing
um without there being some sort of like
noble element like this i just there's
just something that we don't know about
sharon carter
that in her motives that i i don't think
that she's fully
working for the power broker i think
that there's something going on
that she's using bad truck for because i
i feel like bad track seems pretty
not thrilled about doing this mission i
mean that's the box
i'm getting but he seems compelled like
he's being blackmailed into doing it or
paid but if you don't take this money
and do it we're going to make your life
hell in other ways we'll get
back in that algerian prison um now
there is some speculation right now that
um julia
julia louise drive his character was
supposed to actually appear in black
widow
uh and this is coming from vanity fair
but i want you guys to read that article
because they keep referencing just this
2019 interview
with the veep cast in which tony hale
just made some
comment about um julie louie dreyfus
being able to play a great disney
villain
and then dry fish just kind of runs with
it and says like oh yeah i'll be able to
shoot fire out of my hands and stuff
a disney villain it's not a marvel
villain per se even though disney owns
marvel they weren't talking about you're
going to be at the mcu they just kind of
i think they were referring to her like
to um you know
angelina jolie in those movies you know
like to where she's just like a badass
and she can be
this kind of witch or this uh fairy tale
character who's a badass
um so while it's interesting i wouldn't
call this a scoop
that for sure julia lee dreifus is
supposed to be in the black widow movie
she might i just
someone point to me the actual quote
that says she was going to be in black
widow in particular
because i haven't found that yet um
maybe it's out there but uh you
mentioned the thunderbolts empty
and it's very possible that val's
interest in walker could mean she's
assembling a team of anti-heroes the way
nick fury assembled the avengers which
kind of seemed like the tone of her
entrance there
kind of a sense of humor you know focus
on her boots she's got this big long
coat
um and this could be the beginning of
the mcu thunderbolts
um only because with that streak in her
hair she kind of has some vibes like
victoria hand
deputy director the thunderbolts during
the dark green um
who also has a similar hair style
actually victoria hand wasn't agents of
shield she was killed off so maybe
that's
why they aren't naming her victoria hand
they pulled some other characters
related to
nick fury and team assembly and that
kind of thing and
that maybe she does appear in some of
these other titles taking these
anti-heroes and putting together a team
um and i just think that i'm feeling
torn between hydra she's madame hydra
and
just this character who is setting up
the thunderbolts only because
she's interested in him having the super
soldier serum and she says that like
the a little state secret which hydra
knows state secrets but she seems like
someone who's working within
the confines of the law like she's not
afraid to walk around
uh and recruit people but recruit
unpopular people
um so between so i think just to kind of
narrow down those five options we got
she could be head of hydra
she could be putting together the new
thunderbolts she could be part of the
scrolls
uh she could be part of this them force
type of adaptation
or she could be the power broker herself
or related to the power broker
of those five empty are you feeling
hydra
i'm thinking that it it could it's more
i think it's more likely to be
hydra but i also think that there could
be
a connection to maybe nick fury like she
has in the comics maybe she's
working or she has a like actually has a
pass with nick fury
and i used to work with shield and
maybe i mean maybe she is hydra yeah i'm
gonna go with hydra yeah
i just made up my mind it's probably
hydra yeah i'm i'm
kind of torn between that and
thunderbolts but i i it could be hydra
i'm just wondering like why wouldn't
they say that right now
like why but we know hydra operatives
are can kind of be goofball like senator
stern in uh an iron man 2
and captain america winter soldier these
people can have senses of humor for sure
as she seems to have but i'm just
wondering uh
how is is someone like her on bucky's
list because he
seems to know everyone who is in hydra
he was a winter soldier
would she have been able to hide and get
away with it for that long
maybe maybe she seems to be a very
smart operator who doesn't have time for
stupid questions
um i'm just right now based off of the
context of that scene she was recruiting
john walker
it's not necessarily about her and her
past it's about her plan
yeah and i think her plan right now
seems to be she
wants a super soldier who has no other
allegiances or loyalties
and to me that just sounds more
thunderbolts than
in bringing back hydra just because i
i'm necessarily personally not
i'm not necessarily that interested in
uh and what hydra's plans are in the
future
that feels like something that was a big
deal on agents of shield and in uh phase
two
of marvel but i kind of want to see what
other dangerous organizations there are
out there now in the future but that's
just me
yeah i mean for me personally i i really
do think that hydra is setting
themselves for a comeback
because we haven't really seen them
since uh like basically age of ultron
i mean like you know obviously agents of
shield but like i don't
personally think that the the non-mcu
shows are
canon anymore but it's fine yeah um but
like no
um i i think that hydra
with with sam wilson um being set up to
be the new captain america
i think that hydra is going to come back
and um i think i honestly think
red skulls eventually got to come back
and like you know
they're going to play a bigger role
again because like they've always
you know throughout the comics they've
been defeated and they come back
defeated and they come back they're just
regular um just a force in the in the
marvel universe that they people can't
get rid of
so i i definitely think that we could be
getting some hydra teases by the end of
um
episode six sort of like a and now
they're back sort of and like
kevin feige and like for me anyway these
disney plush shows seems to be
setting up reasons for um you know
story elements in the move like for
story elements
in future movies to make sense for
example with um juan division
sets up dr strange and this could set up
the return of hydra in a future
um you know captain america movie with
sam wilson or um
just in general for the mcu um so
i don't know i i definitely do think
that this could be a hydra thing but
it could also definitely be a
thunderbolts um setup because
it definitely feels like kevin feige's
setting up a thunderbolt scenario so
i mean it could be both mt the mcu could
kind of retcon the thunderbolts as like
specifically a hydra initiative and that
hydra's things like you know what we've
needed is a team of superheroes like the
avengers like shield has had with the
avengers
and then they just say well the hydra
version of that is the thunderbolts and
this could be something that we see in
black widow as well like
the we have the elena bulova we have red
guardian
uh we have these other figures who could
also be recruited to be part of this
team
um but yeah john walker's an interesting
one to watch there's a lot of other bad
guys out there
i mean get agatha harkness on that team
oh absolutely
bro i am all about that like agatha
would be
an amazing spice to the thunder i want
to see a scene with uh with agatha
harkness and valentina you know like the
two those two
longtime sitcom actors uh just
chatting it up would be awesome it would
be such great dialogue it would be so
good they could just go off the rails go
improv
yeah wonderful i think we can presume
this is the cameo that malcolm spellman
was talking about where he said i want
to partner this character with thor
what do you think he meant by that
hell if i know i mean it would be i mean
maybe just for
comedic elements that's what i'm
thinking too
they're both funny yeah they're both
very hilarious people
um so it would be funny to see them
together in a movie that's
not mcu related because i can't see thor
and val really needing to have a chat
yeah but maybe i could i could just uh
like a quick scene
well i mean spelman was kind of put on
the spot there i think he's thinking
like he was really excited for
julie louis dreyfus to come in the show
uh he's she's so funny the way she like
owns that scene just someone who like
when they walk in a room
she's the alpha of that room and the way
that thor kind of is like
just to imagine those two in a room
together who are just competing for
attention
would be pretty fun dude seeing her and
tony stark if he was alive rest in peace
um it would be hilarious uh well we have
a lot to talk about from this episode
we're gonna get to some more questions
first we want to thank some people
helped us make this episode
starting with stamps.com so are you
still going to the post office and
paying full price for postage
mt never never why would i when
stamps.com
exists that's right thanks to stamps.com
you don't have to do that anymore you
can mail and ship
anytime anywhere right from your
computer stamps.com saves businesses
thousands of hours
and tons of money every year stamps.com
brings the services of the us postal
service and ups
right to your computer whether you're a
small office sending invoices a side
hustle etsy shop or shipping out orders
or if you're like us here at new
rockstars we use stamps.com a lot
because we're all working remotely
you get discounts of up to 40 off post
office rates and up to 66
off ups rates stamps.com saves you time
and money
it's no wonder nearly 1 million small
businesses already use stamps.com so
stop wasting time going to the post
office and go to stamps.com instead
there's no risk and with our promo code
one division we got we got the old one
from the last show
one division is our promo code uh you
get a special offer that includes a four
week trial plus
free postage and a digital scale no
long-term commitments or contracts just
go to stamps.com click on the microphone
at the top
of the home page and type in
wandavisionstamps.com promo code
onedivisionstamps.com never go to the
post office again
never now we also want to thank our
friends at bambas they make the most
comfortable socks in the history of feet
look how limber i am where i can move my
foot up here
to show you my bombers that is some
great flexibility don't do any weird
stuff with that internet
why did i do that never show that it's
too late eric you've shown your feet
it's out there um well bombas has
literally rethought every little detail
of the socks we wear to make them way
more comfortable i wear them pretty much
every day i love the fit and the comfort
they're great with shoes they're just
walking around the house and just socks
which
i love doing i love doing that they do
more than keep feet cozy they help give
back to the most vulnerable members of
our community
for every pair of socks you purchase
bombas donates a pair to someone in need
the generosity of bombas customers has
allowed them to donate over
40 million pairs of socks and counting
through their nationwide network of over
3 000 giving partners and the impact is
more powerful than ever to those
experiencing homelessness
these socks represent the dignity of
putting on clean clothes a small
comfort that's especially important
right now so give a pair when you buy a
pair and get 20
off your first purchase at bombus.com
marvel
that's b o m b a s dot com slash marvel
for 20
off your first purchase bombus.com
marvel and our friends at helix sleep
you know we've been staying up late on
thursday nights watching and re-watching
these falcon winter soldier episodes
we're probably not getting enough sleep
but the sleep we are getting is really
good because of helix mattresses
this is what you do you take a quiz on
the helix website and they match you to
the right mattresses
just for you soft or firm whatever they
have the right mattress just for you i
got matched with the right mattress for
my sleep style i've never slept better
they ship it right to your door and you
don't have to drive all over town with a
mattress on the roof of your camry
just try it for 100 nights risk-free
and they were rated number one best
overall mattress pick of 2020 by gq and
wired magazine
just go to helixsleep.com inside marvel
take their two minute sleep quiz and
they'll match you to the customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life
helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners at helix sleep.com
inside marvel that's helix sleep.com
inside marvel for up to 200
off and two free pillows all right back
to the show mt
what is our next what the falcon well
i'm glad you asked this eric because the
next what the falcon of the day
is what the falcon is in the box that
bucky gave sam
that's a really intriguing question and
i
i honestly think that it's probably his
new suit
with like completely new captain america
suit with
vibranium wings and uh just sam's gonna
be ready to go to fight
potentially john walker and the flag
smashers
but what do you think i i agree with you
uh i think they're waiting to show it
off because it's gonna look
awesome now do we think the color scheme
of that blue and white is what we're
looking at is this going to be like the
the stealth suit that a cap wore in a
captain america winter soldier
or it's just that blue and white or is
that just the color of the box
i think that that's that's just the
color of the box i think we're just
gonna get the full red white and blue
very familiar very similar to the the
captain america sam wilson comics
um just straight up captain america suit
and it's gonna look
fire um yeah i'm wondering if is it just
gonna be a cosmetic change are there
gonna be some like new
upgrades i have to imagine if it's
coming from the labs of wakanda yeah
vibranium um not only is it gonna be
sturdier
is it gonna have that kind of like you
know how shuri had
the mesh um nanotech where it could just
kind of
shapeshift and change are the well the
shield
or shield well the wings kind of
re-materializes the shield by just like
stitching back together automatically to
where they don't have to fold
the way they used to before i don't know
i i i think it might
still be very non-nanotech based though
i think that there might be um maybe
it's like maybe a neural
type deal because like with with black
panther um t'challa could just think and
his in his helmet can go on
so like maybe um sam wilson just be like
all right i'm thinking that i want my
wings to open up and then they'll just
open up by themselves rather than him
doing anything
though i don't know how they work in
general but yeah i don't know i think
that
there's a potential for any real thing
to happen because sherry's a technology
genius
but um we're different going to see some
type of upgrade
um for sure and his wings are definitely
going to be full vibranium and way more
sturdier
than his last pair that just got ripped
off by john walker
my question is how much will it uh
embody the
color scheme and the symbolism of the
red white and blue stars and stripes
we've seen some kind of like comic book
imagery where falcon has that big star
on his chest
but after this conversation with isaiah
bradley i think it's going to emphasize
sam's like blackness and not shy away
from that if
you're having the wakandans design it
the way the black panther suit
embodied like wakandan culture in that
whole aesthetic
i have to wonder like why would you have
the wakandans design it
it's not just for vibranium i think it's
also for their aesthetic and their
cultural choices
and i think that's going to be reflected
in that suit i think
that would be really dope i hope so
that'd be really cool to see that yeah
because in the meantime it seems like
torres is being set up to be falcon
i think so like or at least a protege
falcon junior
or something like why leave the broken
wings with him if you're not setting
that up
maybe they could do just like a you know
a cap a winged captain america and
uh a toy in a falcon like two winged
people um
just kind of like going back to like you
know sam's days with riley it's like now
i got my wingman now we're two wingmen
and like we're
we're captain america wing a f winged
themed captain america team um yeah
but i don't know we'll see i mean taurus
is definitely going to get those wings
by the end of the season
um but whether or not cap's new suit has
wings
um is up in the air yeah
um now uh our next what the falcon
uh what the falcon is sharon carter's
plan what is her relationship with bad
truck
how did you read this scene mt i i
honestly feel
like again sharon is working on behalf
of some type of
governmental organization or or
intelligence agency
and is blackmailing batroc to use him to
either interrupt the flag smashers plans
like sort of like a mole in their
operation
or i don't know like it's she's just so
mysterious
um yeah i think that she is pretending
to work on behalf of the power broker
but has access to you know she had
access to those satellites
and that helped bucky and sam in the
last episode
and so and we we all know who uses
satellites right now
sword swords that has satellites up in
the sky so like maybe she could be
working on behalf of sword
um but who knows who really knows yeah i
mean tony stark also had
satellites and he was a private scenario
it's true so if you're wealthy enough
in this universe you can have satellites
um but
i i think you are right she's working on
behalf of someone we haven't gotten
answers on her yet
um i assume we will next episode it's
totally possible we never really get any
firm answers on what's going on with
sharon carter
if she we'll see i if she is working on
behalf of the government i just wonder
like
it just feels like a lot of steps like
she's
like why would the government set her up
to be this high this arts dealer who's
dealing with stolen art like she could
just be an operative without that
whole side of her job like it's just a
weird thing that feels like she's
working for
some wealthy criminal organization that
might not be the power broker
it might be the power broker i just
feels like the information we've been
given about
her is that she is in madrapore she has
some kind of connections with the
criminal underworld and
she knows a lot about the power broker
she knew about dr nagle working for the
power broker
she has access to satellites she's
pissed off at the avengers for
for kind of abandoning her uh and she's
super rich
she has this nice ass penthouse in high
town
so to me like if they also add something
like
and that was all a cover and she's
working for thaddeus ross or some kind
of government organization it'd be like
well why all those extra steps um or
maybe she is just like a john wick
person working for
some elite criminal and that person
could be the power broker
what i just want to wonder is like why
would the power broker now
align itself with the flag smashers like
what do they hope to gain
by dismantling the grc's plans
uh i don't know what the if she's
working on behalf of the government
why is she working against the grc by
sending that truck in to help the flag
smashers i guess
i mean i i honestly i honestly truly
believe that
um sharon sent him to fight the flag
smashers or to interrupt their plans
because like i think that he's a mole
within the flag smashers right now
he's just that that element that isn't
part of their team that's just like all
right now i'm here to help
and i don't know i don't know who oh
yeah okay that could be the case that
could totally be the case again it just
feels like extra steps like it feels
like
uh like uh maybe you're right maybe
you're right
like it's madrapore man majapur is a
criminal
land and like if you are not a criminal
then you're basically
i feel like you're just no one wants you
around so like i feel like to establish
a deep cover
sharon had to you know make it look like
all right now i'm this art dealer
working for
this powerful person so like everyone
trusts me like you see in the last
episode
she's walking through those barricades
and they're just like hey sharon
what's going on like we trust you
because like this is
this could potentially just be a deep
cover so or they legitimately trust her
because she is
in this criminal organization you never
know
you never know so it's either what it's
either one of those i
i think that she's in a deep cover just
because of
her like the character that has been
established within the mcu already i
mean
she was a close ally to steve rogers
yeah yeah she was
a neighbor but was someone working for
shield spying on him yeah
exactly so like even though you know the
government may have
let her down potentially i just don't
think that she would go this far
to be this criminal in madrid without
i don't know some type of secret like oh
that was just fake the whole time and
now i was
working for this secret cia or some [ __ ]
i don't know
but um yeah i mean look every episode i
i feel like i'm always rethinking or i'm
overthinking her too much it could just
be as simple as you know how like
in in game the writers are like well
what's the furthest extreme we can take
hawkeye what's it for this extreme we
can take hulk and thor
we made thor overweight and drunk we
made uh
hulk uh like he's now just smart he's a
smart hulk he fused the brains with
lebron
uh hawkeye's become a murderous uh
assassin vigilante
throughout the world and i think they're
doing something similar with sharon
carter they're saying the
in the aftermath of the blip it just
changed people's priorities
this much to where now that she's been
abandoned by her country this is the
choice she made
is to work and work her way up through
the criminal world i think
she was meant as a foil for for bucky
and sam like if you're gonna be runaways
from your government
um like this is what you can do with
your abilities
you can make a [ __ ] ton of money and i
think it was something meant for sam
someone who is economically struggling
with his family and getting a bank loan
i think it was meant as a tease for sam
to be like i could have this
i could work here i just think if you're
writing these things that's what you
write
it's rare where you write like but also
it was all fake but also she's working
for
it's really hard to write that way and
it's often very unsatisfying for viewers
when you try to reveal that
so i think as screenwriters they just
try to like they don't spend all this
time writing exposition just to reveal
that exposition to be evident to the
contrary
i've
one quick thing i like you brought up
brought up hawkeye because that got me
thinking
i wonder if hawkeye has has been to
madrapore
because he spent some time in he must
have the continent of asia
and he's been deal he was spending some
time fighting criminals in asia
so like maybe he's went to madrid just
to get some leads or something i don't
know
um but maybe like in potentially his
actions in
um it was japan right with um that fight
yes tokyo yes tokyo um
he maybe he created a power vacuum that
maybe dominoes were falling and like if
it affects what sharon carter is doing
who knows but um yeah anyway we might
not
uh uh i i will be surprised at this
point
if they reveal if we meet the power
broker in the flesh
in this series like if they reveal it to
be sharon carter or val
like i i would just be surprised they
might have relation business
relationships with him
or be trying to bust him or to overthrow
him
or something like that but i think it's
more likely we'll get a tease of who the
power broker is
whether it's a hydra symbol or a 10 ring
symbol or whatever it is and we'll leave
it
for a future installment to dig into
that but i
i think julie would louis dreyfus was
our big cameo
or big casting thing i'd be surprised if
there was
like another one because that kind of
sucks the wind out of the sales of the
previous one
because then it's like oh this is a show
that revealed julie louis dreyfus in it
but it's also the show that revealed
this other person it just kind of takes
away from their own headline
you know yeah that's true it's true
um but yeah your guess is as good as
mine exactly what sharon carter's plan
is to me it seems like i don't know why
she would invest so much in batroc
to just uh bring down the flag smashers
plan because it kind of takes the
narrative stakes out of uh
sam and bucky going to stop them if they
already have someone from the ins like i
don't imagine them fighting on the same
side as bad truck
uh to bring down the flag smashers um
unless they say hey the grc needs to be
stopped we're going to join the flag
smashers and beating batrack but then is
batroc the big bad in that final battle
i
i'm not that eager to see that
big bad bad truck yeah um
but it is interesting that sharon carter
is linked with him
it means that she's been paying him she
paid him that initial mission in episode
one right
yeah that's what i'm assuming anyway i'm
just like that's well that's exactly
what i was thinking about i was like
what why would sharon need this soldier
person
like what does the soldier like what
intel does this soldier have that sharon
would need
yeah i don't know i think uh the power
broker just has
that's why i keep thinking ten rings
because the tin rings is just everywhere
they have spies everywhere
and they're like they're always trying
to destabilize certain parts of the
world to gain weapons tech to gain some
kind of political advantage
uh i can't i'm like are there are
probably a lot of organizations in the
world that are like that
but they just seem to fit the bill but
we haven't gotten any evidence really
that it's them
um so for now let's move on to our next
what the falcon
what do you think is john walker's next
move mt
i think that that dude um wants to
get the shield back i think that he
wants to be captain america so badly
and like he we do see him um make this
his own shield at the end of the episode
um i don't know if you guys
like if you guys miss the the extra
credit team there is a post credit scene
so spoilers for that but yeah he's
making his
own um fake captain america shield
and that explains the different shield
that we see in the trailers
and that why it has like different
grooves in the center
um but his yeah i think that he just
wants to get that shield back so he can
live this fantasy as captain america
even though he's not anymore
yeah i have to imagine that shield that
he's building in his garage is not made
of
like vibranium or anything because i
don't think you can just get like a
blowtorch and weld vibranium that easily
um but uh yeah i think he is on a
downward spiral
right now um i this explains why that
shield looked different but he did a
pretty good job making a cosplay shield
i gotta say
it's a really good minus shield yeah
like that would get you a lot of
pictures at comic con
oh yeah just you did a really good job
that's a fantastic did a great job
um but he has some kind of suit just
based off of promo footage where you see
him walking down the street with that
shield
he's gonna suit back up um this might be
what valve's organization suits him back
up with
um but i yeah i uh
i i he's he's gonna try to redeem
himself redeem
his name and he's going to try to finish
the job of the flag smashers i think
once he finds out where carly is
he's going to try to kill carly and i
think at some point sam's going to have
to defend carly
against john walker trying to murder
someone publicly
again yeah i think that yeah john's
gonna do something crazy
in the last episode that's going to
really ruin his reputation
i'm assuming um and just
put a just have him just go on this
spiral and just like
maybe i think that at the end of this
the government ends up using john walker
again
as you know with as you us agent um and
just like hey you are dark but we need
we need someone that's tough
that's willing to do the dark [ __ ]
undercover so
yeah we're going to hire you and you're
going to do some really crazy [ __ ] for
us
well that's what i yeah i think he slash
val are going to rebrand him u.s
agent and that's why i think val might
be more involved with a thunderbolts
plot than a hydroplot just because i
think she's kind of
going to be like marvel's amanda waller
she's going to be like
task force x i'm putting together a team
of criminals of people who society does
not want to work with or look at as a
hero
to do the really dirty missions yeah i
think that's a
pretty fair guess that seems pretty
like something john walker would do so
yeah yeah but real quick we want to
thank someone else who helped us make
this episode
we got to talk about our friends at
bluetooth bluetooth is
the unique online service that delivers
the same active ingredients as viagra
and cialis but in chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost blue chew is an
online prescription service so
no visits to the doctor's office no
awkward conversations no waiting in the
line of pharmacy and it ships right to
your door in a discreet package
process is simple sign up at
bluetooth.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within days it's all done
online
bluetooth license medical providers work
with you to find the right ingredient
and strength for your prescription
bluetooth tablets are made in the usa
they prepared and shipped direct it's
cheaper than a pharmacy so if you could
benefit from extra confidence when it's
time to perform visit bluetooth.com for
more details and important safety
information
and we've got a special deal for our
listeners try bluetooth free when you
use our promo code inside marvel at
checkout just pay the five dollars in
shipping that's bluetooth.com promo code
inside marvel to receive your first
month free thanks bluetooth for
sponsoring the show
mt i want to ask you one final question
the wakandans why do you think they're
keeping zemo in the raft
uh what does that tell us about the role
in world security right now what does
this mean for zemo
i think that they sent zemo to the raft
rather than taking him himself because
they just wanted to keep their
relationships with everyone
super kosher because like they kind of
deserve to get zemo but
they're just like all right here we're
just gonna put you in the most secure
facility ever so you don't escape
and underwater and yeah
i feel like this tells me that the dora
milaj milaje are
trying to just play nice and just like
make everyone just be like hey what kind
of you know they they get the job done
like zemo escapes but like they fixed it
and like
they brought it and like they were just
doing um their duty
so i i just think that they're just
trying to t'challa just wants to be a
good neighbor
yeah but what do you think well i i
think this uh
kind of continues that pattern of
cooperation between the wakandans and
avengers
tech and avengers security forces uh
because the raft was previously
um seemed like something that tony stark
designed and kind of helped
thaddeus ross build to contain super
soldiers but now that the wakandans are
overseeing that is interesting
i think it shows that they might be
world leaders when it comes to these
things that
the rest of the un might look to wakanda
to trust these things in their hands and
why
why shouldn't they because they are the
most advanced nation on earth
they have the most sophisticated
technology to handle this stuff
um but either way auntie i think zemo is
going to break out of that prison
oh yeah definitely zemo breaks out or
he's approached by
ross and he's like listen um we're
making a team
and i'd like you on it um and it it
definitely feels like
it could be a seeds for um another
thunderbolt type of scenario but
i'm just on thunderbolts watch for this
episode in general
because we're running so many watches we
were on mephisto watch we were on zola
watch
hydro watch there was a hydra watch in
one division
and now we're on thunderbolts watch
i mean like we do have batch rock and
like bring them bringing back rock back
is like the biggest
red flag for me well not red flag but
the biggest um
indicator that some type of thunderbolts
thing is
is is popping off because zemo and and
batroc
and like we have ghosts in the mcu like
there's so many
different characters that seem like
they're being set up for something so i
guess thunderbolts yeah um so we will
leave it there
but we're gonna move on to our patient
listeners on stereo to answer some of
their questions
but uh that is it for this episode of
inside marvel the falcon winter soldier
after show
uh mt and i will be back next friday for
our reaction episode
season finale uh my easter egg breakdown
is going to come out on the channel
tomorrow for this episode
so follow mt at mastertainment follow me
at eavos follow new rockstar subscribe
to inside marvel for every gear podcast
a reminder you can get our anarchy
assembled shirt
and our new zemo design thank you for
watching we'll close out with our
favorite moment of the episode
bye bye everybody latest
excuse me who are you anyway
you did the right thing
[Music]
so
[Music]